You should have AOC on Alexandra.
Hug Her and I've gone back and forth on Twitter.
Yeah,
that would be really interesting to listen to us.
She's so young.
I'm so interested in how she's 28 years old.
I mean that's amazing.
The whole a,
she's just fascinating.
You should have her on.
How about when she was getting a hard time because a,
they found a video like they thought they were going to get her video college
dancing.
Yeah,
but you know what?
Everyone loved that video.
The whole narrative that like some random person on Twitter put that video out.
Right.
But the point is they,
they did it because they thought they were going to shame her.
They're idiots.
But how funny is that?
They thought it was the most charming thing in the entire world.
Plays anyone who did not love her already fell in love with him.
That's what had accomplished.
And then her response to that was her doing a little dance.
She's a genius.
She's a social media genius.
The question is,
does she,
do her ideas stand up at all?
Well,
she'd be interesting to hear.
Does can evolve.
But what she has,
it's unique and she's real and she seems to be a really good person.
She seems to be a good person.
Now,
whether or not I agree with her tax policy,
I'm not an economist.
I'm a fucking moron.
Okay.
I don't know anything about economics.
I really don't.
I mean you should have her arm,
semicolon
are there.
However,
on PR just,
I just want to know about her as a person for my,
my thoughts on politicians is you can hire a economist,
you could listen to them,
you could talk to them,
but we really need is people that have the right idea as far as we're a human
should go the way we should behave,
the way we should treat each other.
This,
this overwhelming need for community that we all share.
We have to,
we have to pull this thing together and we have to be,
we have to look at each other as a community and that's lacking.
And the people that are polarizing both on the left and the right,
why they don't want to look at it that way.
They don't.
They want to look at people and say,
Hey,
you will never get better like that 16 year old kid.
No need to ever forgive him.
This kind of crazy talk,
whether it's from the right or from the left,
is what we really need to stomp out.
We need to stop.
We need to be nicer to each other.
We need to figure out,
we don't have time.
We're not going to live long.
If you're 50 years old and this is your idea of the world,
like,
fuck man,
you're halfway done and you're in it.
You're an idiot.
You're looking at shit completely wrong and you're halfway done with this trip.
If everything goes perfect,
right.